[Applaudissements]
vous permet de gagner du temps d'accord
très bien alors minorant les coudes
thierry l'ait déjà consulté vous bien le
mot noix de coco on va d'abord mettez
vous donnant les noix de coco une les
noix de coco une qui se met dans la noix
de coco une des reliques de votre équipe
c'est vous dire thierry hocquet thierry
la loi sauf qu une peut-être avec ce qui
nous rattrape qui tu veux c'est aux tirs
et qui devrait le plus fort vous mettez
dans la noix de coco et aller s'il vous
plaît qui se met devant la une gilles
penet dès lors à la une gilles de gilles
devant la cour l'un d'eux l'a 2 et
isabelle devant la 3 johnny c'est vous
qui allez donner le top c'était vous me
mettez votre notebook ou venez attention
attention et on commence par là une donc
c'est irina tankiste thierry enora et on
tire la langue pour finir bien sûr
attention pour thierry énorme d'abord
c'est cévennes aura d'abord droit de 1 m
c'est toi qu'est ce que c'est alors
montré ce que fait pacifique
eric a fait monter le film serait la
dose et et gilles noisy le sec et celle
là c'est la 2 sara maude juneau
[ __ ] de merde
[Applaudissements]
bush
on attend
attendez attendez attendez les études
années on pouvait manger qu'un petit
morceau rap affaire comme dans koh lanta
exactement et nos ateliers et n'aura
besoin et qui sait le pool et n'aura
droit à rien j'ai une tourelle de verre
alors attention vas-y tu adores gylfi
tout digérer les annonces
[Applaudissements]